[Music]
I have become dear
destroyer of worlds
what led the mild-mannered polymath who
was more interested in philosophy than
War to utter those famous words on a
single day in 1939 Robert Oppenheimer
explained how a star implodes when it
runs out of fuel simultaneously on that
same day John Archibald wheeler
published the first explanation of
atomic fission and Hitler invaded Poland
today we're going to link them all
together and talk about America's
Prometheus Robert Oppenheimer who
brought nuclear fire down to a planet
that was not prepared for what the
atomic age would Unleashed
destroyer of worlds
I suppose we all thought that one way or
another